today on the matt walsh show did
alexandria ocasio-cortez
attend the jesse smilet school of
victimology new revelations cast doubt
on her claims of a
near-death experience during the january
6 riot also
five headlines including john kerry
explaining why he has to travel by
private jet
to save the planet you know it all works
somehow we'll find out how and the news
media is horrified and scandalized by a
grocery store in florida
where people aren't wearing a mask if
you can imagine and in our daily
cancellation
we all contend with the aclu's attempt
to debunk
biological science is biology cancelled
or is the aclu cancelled we'll find out
today that and much more
on the matt wall show
you know part of being an adult is being
prepared
that's that's that's what it means to be
a grown-up is being prepared for
anything that might happen
any catastrophe emergency any situation
that might arise
and that's why you need to look into
ready wise ready wise is the leader in
emergency food supplies they've got
emergency meals they've got freeze dried
fruit and vegetables for convenient on
the go
on the go nutrition they've also got
their new adventure meals for hiking
camping
other outdoor activities that's a time
when you also want to be prepared if
you're going out for a hike
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online and have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep
ready wise products are our products are
proudly made right here in the usa
uh so you're supporting a company that
makes their product in the usa
which is really important i think to all
of us readywise makes being prepared
simple and affordable you can order
online have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep
when preparing our meals all you need is
four cups of water
water doesn't have to have to be hot
that's all you need is the fort cubs
you simply pour the food in into the
water you stir and you cover
about 15 minutes later it's ready to eat
it's also delicious you shouldn't have
to sacrifice taste and nutrition with
emergency food
ready wise uses the finest ingredients
and latest food preparation technology
to ensure
optimal taste and freshness each recipe
is crafted by a team of chefs
to provide delicious nutritional meals
and
i can vouch that the meals are
actually delicious so this week my
listeners can get 10
off at readywise.com when entering walsh
at checkout or by calling
855-475-3089 readywise is a 30-day no
questions asked return policy so there's
no risk
in taking the initiative to get you and
your family prepared today that's
readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code walsh to get 10 off
you know andrew jackson was the first
president to be targeted for
assassination as jackson was leaving a
funeral in 1835
a man named richard lawrence completely
insane as it would turn out
approached the president pulled a pistol
from his coat tried to shoot him
the weapon misfired giving jackson time
to seize lawrence and begin beating him
over the head with his cane his walking
cane
during the scuffle lawrence actually
managed to pull a second pistol
which also misfired later at trial
lawrence declared himself to be king
richard iii
and he was then found not guilty by a
reason of insanity
now the upshot is that jackson managed
to
ward off his own assassin himself armed
only with a cane
and he did this in spite of the fact
that he was 67 years old injured and
sick
and the bullet still embedded in his
lung from a duel three decades before
was the least of his physical maladies
they just they really don't make
politicians like that anymore
it's a shame too because now we're
evicting him from the 20 bill
but at least they don't make politicians
like that anymore in this country now
compare that story that of a sitting u.s
president
engaged in hand-to-hand combat with an
assassin
and that's a real story to a much more
recent drama involving
another prominent public official
representative alexandria caser cortez
now to hear her tell it the incident was
quite similar
according to aoc herself on january 6 a
mob of lunatics had been quote sent
to the capitol by ted cruz and other
republicans to quote
have her murdered she was in her office
when she heard shouting and loud banging
her her life flashed before her eyes she
was forced to lock herself in the
bathroom
huddling against the wall afraid to make
a sound
she she knew that her time was short it
was coming to an end let's listen we
played this a couple days ago let's
listen again
just to a quick clip of her describing
some of this experience
just to refresh our memories here she is
like i'm here
and the bathroom door starts going like
this like the bathroom doors behind me
or rather in front of me and i'm like
this and the door hinges right here
and i just hear where is she where is
she
and um this was the moment
where i thought
everything was over
um
and the weird thing about moments like
these is that you lose
all sense of time um
in retrospect um maybe
it was four seconds maybe it was five
seconds maybe it was 10 seconds
maybe it was one second i don't know it
felt like
my brain was able to have so many
thoughts in that moment between these
screams and these yells
of where is she where is she and so
i go down and i just
i mean i thought i was going to die no
in retrospect it's kind of funny when
you read some of the comments
uh if you're watching that video she was
on instagram live and you see the live
comments from people that were
uh watching her and all these comments
like oh oh my gosh this is unreal this
is unbelievable
well yeah um now she tells us that she
came to terms with her own impending
death
as the rampaging mob tore through the
building
one sort of imagines the scene from lord
of the rings when the orc army is trying
to break down the door to the fortress
as pippen and gandalf
sit there on the other side awaiting the
end
death is just another path gandalf says
calmly
aoc's tale is supposed to have a similar
sort of feel right
she says that she she managed to achieve
a certain inner resolve and peace
as she was facing her demise when she
realized that her work
would be carry on carried on by those
who come after her
and yes she really said that then then a
capitol police
officer barrels through the door but
she still wasn't safe something wasn't
right she tells us
was he there to protect her or was he an
undercover agent working for the other
side
his facial expressions his unpleasant
bedside manner
made her wonder so she prepared to fight
him off if need be even now
she still isn't sure if he was one of
the good guys or not even though she
came to protect her she's still not sure
nevertheless she uh she narrowly made it
to safely safety she lived to fight
another day
though just barely uh and this is the
story
as it was told to us
and then the truth comes out the daily
wire has the report
um quoting now republican representative
nancy mace
whose office is two doors down from
democratic representative alexandra
corte
ocasio-cortez noted that
insurrectionists
never made it to their hall when the u.s
capitol building was breached on january
6th
mace made the note while hitting the
media for their attempts to quote fan
fiction fictitious new flames about the
breach
on january 6 mace tweeted that she left
her office in the canon building
still inside the capitol complex but
some distance from the capital rotunda
and the house chambers
she said at the time just evacuated my
office in canon due to a nearby threat
she wrote now we're seeing protesters
assaulting capitol police
red state reports aoc wasn't even in the
capitol building when all of the action
was going down if she was in her office
she was in the cannon building which is
nearby but a different building
of course many didn't get the logistics
and just assumed that she was in the
capitol building according to
representative
nancy mason was in office in the same
office as aoc two doors away there was
never any rioters in their hall so there
was never any physical danger from
rioters
coming in at any point okay cortez made
clear she didn't know who was at her
door the republican wrote
capturing a post from newsweek
breathless attempts by media to fan
fictitious new flames are dangerous
my office is two two doors down mace
underscored insurrectious never stormed
our hallway
egregious doesn't even begin to cover it
is there nothing the msm
won't politicize well this is a very
different sort of story isn't it
this version which appears to be the
correct version
rather condenses aoc's involvement
if we could put it politely in truth it
would seem
here's what happened she was in her
office never in any direct danger of any
kind
and then she was told to evacuate which
she did without incident
the end that's it that's the story from
this baseline she has weaved a whole
fantasy narrative involving narrow
escapes
murderous mobs just outside her door
hitmen
sent by republican senators to kill her
this is reminiscent of the time when she
went down to the border and broke down
in tears while watching children get
locked in cages
only it turned out that she didn't see
anybody in any cages in fact she was
weeping while staring into an empty
parking lot
very similar sort of situation now aoc
has tried a number of tactics to manage
the pr crisis caused by her own
embellishments
responding to a tweet from jack basobiak
uh who has been doing a lot of the fact
checking on this story
because the media the mainstream news
media won't do the fact checking
um this is what she said in response to
jack she said
this isn't a fact check at all your
arrows aren't accurate they lie about
where the mobs stormed and placed them
further away than it was
you all but you also failed to convey
multiple areas where people were trying
to storm
it wasn't just one you also failed to
show tunnels
poor job all around now hold on a second
tunnels
is she suggesting that the mob went
through the tunnels and made it to her
building
i don't think she's trying to suggest
anything in particular at this point
really this is simply
deflection and of course if you can't
deflect the other strategy at least if
you're a democrat is to censor
so team aoc is apparently now sending
out emails
urging their followers to report anyone
who questions aoc's story
the email urges supporters to quote scan
your social media to find posts with
this
misleading information and then quote
use the built-in
report feature to flag them for
moderators
so this is what you could do if you're a
democrat democrats know that big tech
is on their side ready to help so all
they have to do is throw up the
alley-oop
and the big tech will uh we'll take it
from there you know they're going to put
it through the hoop
along with deflection and censorship the
other strategy is doubling down
right so those are those are three basic
strategies deflection censorship double
down
aoc is employing all of them she's going
for the trifecta
it was actually reported this morning
that house members will come together on
the floor
on thursday night tonight to share their
personal stories of the january 6th riot
alexandria quezo cortez will of course
kick off the event
she'll be there this this is how they're
going to spend
um their time our time
we've got a pandemic we've got lockdowns
we've got economic crisis
and they're going to use the house floor
like a therapy session group therapy
and they're all going to get up there
and tell their stories now personally if
we're going to do this i would much
rather hear the stories
of regular americans who survived blm
writing
how about the woman who was beaten with
two by fours in rochester
by blm rioters i'd like to hear her
story
still it will be interesting to see if
aoc's story has grown
any more dramatic in the last few days
you never know maybe in the newest
version you know
she'll grab a decorative sword from the
wall use it to vanquish a gang of
pirates or something
you know they always get carried away
with the hollywood remakes
now it's easy to laugh at this and uh it
is pretty hilarious after all but
our laughter shouldn't overshadow the
very real scandal
here the fact is that a congresswoman
told a radically embellished story
which included a baseless smear of a
capital police officer not to mention
her previous her previous slander of ted
cruz
accusing him of attempted murder and she
did all of this for reasons of political
expedience
and of course to achieve more victim
points because aoc of all people knows
that the real privilege in america
forget about white privilege the real
privilege in america is
victims privilege if you are actually in
an
ineligible victim of course we know that
a person's race and or political
affiliation may preclude them from
victim status no matter what happens to
them
but if you're eligible for the position
then you can always increase your victim
status and therefore your
social and political capital by making
yourself more and more of a victim
to have the most victim points is to
have the most power
to be the uber victim is to be
untouchable unquestionable
aoc knew she had an opportunity here and
she couldn't let it pass
for the rest of her political career
whenever she's trying to get some policy
through
or some agenda item her argument will
essentially be
i almost died in a riot and you would
dare deny me
how dare you you don't care about
survivors at all
it's a persuasive pitch i mean not to me
but to a lot of people
so that's the game now and that's why
we've gone from politicians who beat
their own assassins over the head with
canes and then carry then
went ahead and carried on with their day
like nothing happened to politicians who
break down in tears and scream
because a police officer frowned at them
it's not a matter of being overly
sensitive let's not mistake this this is
about
power for all of aoc's talk about social
justice and helping the less fortunate
and so on
this power is all she really cares about
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i just saw this tweet from mayor de
blasio in new york
and i thought this was funny because
this is just he's linking to an art i
think it's a bloomberg article
um and uh but his caption says move over
austin because
as the song says if you can make it here
you can make it anywhere and it's easier
than ever for young dreamers to make it
in the greatest city in the world
so he's talk you know talk about new
york obviously and he's encouraging
people to come to new york
um and as the mayor of the city it's
part of his job is to try to get people
to come
move there um but he can't even do that
right
this guy is such an incompetent boob
that he can't even do that right
if you can make it here you can make it
anywhere that's supposed to be a sales
pitch for the city
because you can you invert that and say
what you're actually saying is it's
harder to make it here than anywhere
else
that's your pitch because i could say
that about like
living inside a volcano if you can make
it inside a volcano then you can make it
anywhere if you can make it in the
amazon rainforest
then you can make it anywhere that's
probably true but it's not going to be
my first
choice though i'd rather go to the
places that are easier
to make it easier because you know
the local government isn't working
against me at every step of the way
easier because they're not taxing me
into oblivion easier because
um i can afford to live in more than
just uh
you know a studio apartment with
rodents the size of small cats like that
that's what that's what i would prefer
personally
but if you're trying to pitch i guess in
fairness though if you're trying to get
people to move to new york at this point
um there's not a lot to work with so
he's doing the best he can
all right john kerry was um asked
yesterday about how he squares his
private jet habit with his fight against
climate change
i thought his answer is great because he
tries to explain
that actually he needs the private jet
in order to stop climate change
let's listen on that issue pollution i
understand that you came here with a
private jet
is that an environmental way to travel
if you offset
your carbon it's the only choice for
somebody like me
who is traveling the world to win this
battle
i negotiated the paris accords for the
united states
i've been involved in this fight for
years i negotiated with president xi to
bring president xi to the table so we
could get paris and
i believe the time it takes me to get
somewhere i can't sail across the ocean
i have to fly
to meet with people and get things done
but what i'm doing
almost full time is working to win the
battle
of climate change and in the end uh if i
offset
and contribute my life to do this i'm
not going to be put on the defensive
offset my carbon uh
what's the science behind that how does
that work exactly what's the exchange
rate
does he have a chart or something you
tax up on the refrigerator so one
so you fly in a private jet one time and
then
recycle two milk cartons
and plant a tree and it and it's that
about equals
we're fair fair square earth okay don't
be mad at me
oh he has to fly around so he can do the
job well you can't do a zoom
meeting like everybody else has been
doing that's not going to be enough you
have to actually fly there and if you do
fly there you can't take commercial
oh you can't take a boat why not you're
the one telling us that
it's this is do or die the whole the
world might end
this we're facing the apocalypse but
then we're trying to avert the
apocalypse
there there is nothing that should be
too radical
in trying to address that problem and in
fact people like john kerry and
democrats would agree with that usually
they would say there's no
alexandria cases of cortez the green new
deal nothing is too radical
for us though see there is no sacrifice
too radical
for us for you for me but for john kerry
he can't even sacrifice sacrifices
private jet the rest of us can sacrifice
everything but but not him
that's the way it goes now this is a
common complaint
it it um is so common
because it's how this happens so often
that the people who are environmental
champions are the ones who are most
guilty of by their logic destroying the
environment
but the problem is it becomes almost
cliche to bring it up because we're so
used to it
and it's it is often viewed as almost a
cheap shot
to bring up how people like this are
flying on private jets but it's not a
cheap shot
this is it's actually very important
any more than it's a cheap shot when
you've got a pastor or a priest at your
church who's involved in a sex scandal
if you go to that church and you care
about the sex scandal
that's not a cheap shot on your part
it's not irrelevant
because the fact that the pastor priest
is saying one thing in the pulpit
but then living this double life not
even trying to live by
the things that he preaches and his his
actual
uh lifestyle so completely contradicts
everything he says
well what that tells you is that he
doesn't really believe what he says
or at least it's a very good indication
of hypocrisy it's what hypocrisy is it's
saying things you don't believe
and you can't have someone leading your
church who doesn't believe the doctrines
can you climate change is its own
religious doctrine
and so it is it's it's very interesting
that al
almost all the high priests and high
priestesses
of climate change don't appear to really
believe the doctrine
and when this becomes so common then you
start to real then you start to think
hmm
maybe there's a problem with the
doctrine
that the people who profess to know the
most about it and are the most focused
on it
don't actually believe it in in their
personal life they take it about as
seriously as i do
which is i don't really take it
seriously at all but i'm still not
flying on private jets
that is a sacrifice that i have chosen
to make
not going on private jets all right um
the daily wire has the news on the go
gloating golden globe the glowden gobe
nominations the gold globe nominations
are out and i
you know if this is this is also really
important so i figured
if you didn't hear about these
nominations let's go through
some of them uh golden globes coming up
78th annual
okay best most motion picture drama
here are the nominees
the father mank
nomad land promising young woman and the
trial of the chicago seven
i i i'm not trying to be funny when i
tell you i have no idea
what any of these movies are i didn't i
didn't even know that any of these
movies existed
with the exception of the trial the
chicago seven that movie i knew about
uh the rest of them what mank
the father have
um okay best performance by an actress
in a motion
picture um viola davis in
ma rainey's black bottom what
do these movies is this a joke is this
some sort of
parody article in the daily wire
um andra day in the united states vs
billie holiday
vanessa kirby pieces of a woman
francis mcdormand nomad land kerry
mulligan promising young woman
best performance by an actor rhys ahmed
in sound of metal
chadwick boseman ma rainey's black
bottom
anthony hopkins the father gary oldman
bank
uh i have never heard of any of these
movies this is the first time this has
actually happened
and i actually i'm uh i wouldn't call
myself a movie buff but i
i i think i generally stay up to date on
what movies are out
i enjoy movies never heard of these
number three the mass cops are now out
in force so watch out for this this is
from reason it says americans are now
required to wear masks in planes trains
buses subways taxes car services boats
and transportation hubs
per a new order from the cdc masks must
be of a style approved by the federal
government must fit properly
failure to comply will result in being
prohibited from traveling booted from
the transit in question
hopefully if you're on a plane you won't
be booted mid-flight but who knows
and potential criminal penalties the
order will be enforced by the tsa of
course and other federal authorities
as well as state and local officials
this is what they're going to be focused
on is if you're wearing a mask now
speaking of masks though
um i want to play this for you cnbc
had a shocking report at least they're
shocked
by it about people at a grocery store
not wearing a mask this is one grocery
store down in florida somewhere
people aren't wearing a mask and this
made headline news at cnbc let's uh
let's watch
you know we all fantasize about a time
when we won't have to wear
the masks anymore it's not now but some
at a supermarket in florida
appear to have decided that the time is
now
look at this this was the scene at oak's
farm seed and
to table market in naples today
brock took this video which went viral
it looks like it was taken pre-pandemic
right
most customers and employees not wearing
masks at all
the store's policy includes mask
exemption guidelines
the sign says if you have a medical
condition that you don't have to wear a
mask and
nobody inside will ask about medical
conditions so
masks are not enforced the owner told
sam brock this
when questioned about the policy is your
position about medical exemptions or is
it about the fact that you don't think
masks work and
the virus is not a real i know the mass
don't work and i know that the virus has
not
has not killed 400 000 people in this
country that's
total hogwash florida does not have a
mask
mandate but masks do work the science is
crystal clear
in july the cdc director said the united
states could get
covid under control in four to eight
weeks
if we would only all wear masks
shocking horrifying the only thing
that's horrifying is i wish i had a
place like that where i live
i wish there was a store like that i
i really hated some so many things to
hate about uh
what has happened over the last year or
so but one of the worst
is this normalization of snitching
everyone's just become a bunch of
tattletails and it's especially
annoying for me because i spend so much
of my time
at home uh dealing with tattletailing
because my kids especially my daughter
are way into the tattletail phase now
and my daughter is just a narc i mean
she's patrolling
the house constantly looking for people
to tell on and including me
and and my wife like if she catches one
of us doing something she thinks it's
against the rule she'll tell on us to
the other parent
so i'm constantly telling my kids we do
we don't tattletail we don't tattletail
but the entire country becoming a bunch
of tattletails
look if there are people at this store
here's the thing
as far as i know and if i'm wrong about
this then i will correct the record and
i will apologize for being wrong but as
far as i know
the guy who runs that grocery store is
not sending
armed goons out to kidnap people
and and point guns at them and force
them to go shop at his grocery store
now that would be an interesting
business strategy
um you know there might be something to
be said for it but i don't think that's
what he's doing
so everybody that's there they're there
because they choose to be
because they want to be they're not
wearing the mask because they don't want
to wear it there's
i can assume there's not one person in
that store
who is really very concerned about it
because if they were they wouldn't be
there
the only person concerned about it is
the is the snitch
with the camera filming them
everybody else this is a choice they've
made
my body my choice
this is one it's like the one area
where that slogan actually kind of makes
some sort of sense
i'll if i want to put the mask over my
over my own body
i will if i don't i won't but of course
the my
body my choice crowd nowhere to be found
on that
number four since we're on the subject
of potential
hoaxes um people attending the justice
millett school of hoaxing
here's another possible ones from more
news from the daily wires says evanston
illinois school board member elizabeth
lindsey
ryan earlier this month claimed that she
was the victim of a misogynistic and
homophobic hate crime
the problem however is that no one is
willing to share the police report she
allegedly made of the incident
lindsey ryan wrote a statement that was
released by the district 65 school board
on january 11th
according to the college fix um
here's a statement this is what she
claims
this weekend i was the target of a hate
crime the motive of the motive of the
perpetrator was clear my car and
personal belongings ransacked along with
a message of homophobic hate language
prominently displayed there's another
one of those
notes left on the car things now you
can't help but notice that
like every single time this is a hoax
has there been in the last 20 years one
time
when there was a hateful note left on
someone's car
uh and it was and it was authentic
i would have to assume that it actually
has happened a few times just the law of
averages but
i can't think of one all the ones that
come to mind were fake anyway so this is
what she says um
she says there's there was nothing
stolen this wasn't a burglary it was the
intent to terrorize while this
experience was both heartbreaking and
terrifying for my family it's a result
of white supremacy colluding with
misogyny and homophobia to inflict the
most harm possible
while homophobia was utilized in an
attempt to silence me it is not working
in isolation it's part of a greater
collaboration to derail my commitment to
racial equity
i feel compelled to join board
leadership in issuing a message to our
community that offers important context
for this occurrence
okay and they're you know they're making
hay with this and um she's a victim
and so on and so forth uh and if it
really happened then you know she is a
victim of uh someone being
very nasty to her but but the
interesting thing
is that various outlets including the
college fix
have have made multiple attempts
they've contacted her they've contacted
the school board they tried to contact
her through apparently
multiple different ways emails and
messages and so on
um just asking if they could see can we
see the police report
is there any photographic evidence
anything else you could tell us about
this
after all if there's some bigot out
there you know on the loose
vandalizing cars we want to know about
it
but so far those attempts to look at the
police report
have gone um unanswered
so we'll see could be the same people we
remember uh althea bernstein
where was she she was in wisconsin and
she claimed that some
guys in hawaiian shirts some white guys
accosted her at a at a
an intersection and doused her with
lighter fluid and set her on fire
and uh you know but but again there
there's
the the police looked at all the
security cameras around there's a
security camera at the intersection ever
they they could not find this on camera
so either it didn't happen or maybe
these were you know
they could have been invisible could
have had invisibility cloaks or
something we don't know
maybe it's the same people is what i'm
saying it's possible
hey that's the twist ending to all this
there's one group
of bigots highly skilled
they're responsible for jesse smallett
althea bernstein
alexandra casa cortez uh bubba wallace
they put the rope in the garage who
knows
all right number five finally this video
was making the rounds uh this week going
viral it's a 33 year old
arthritic decrepit flightless crippled
one-eyed bat named
statler that's his name not to be
confused with stelter brian stelter
who some say is also a crippled one-eyed
bat but but this bat
was the uh was the subject of a
heartwarming viral video
showing how caretakers at some kind of
bat conservatory
take care of him and even fly him around
around the room
because uh but he can't fly anymore but
he does he's blind as a bat so
he doesn't know any better and a lot of
people think this video is very
heartwarming so let's let's check it out
he goes out for his flights daily
[Music]
because of all the injuries and his age
we hold him
we fly him into the kitchen
[Music]
do the huge bowl of snacks and let him
grab his snacks
[Music]
he looks around like he's actually
flying
[Music]
maybe he's thinking about his younger
years we hope
statler is 33.
uh you know i don't i don't mean to be
too harsh but i watched that am i the
only one
i watched and i think first of all
disgusting
is that if you saw that thing outside
your house
this old bat waddling around
trembling like would you think oh that's
cute
but also and i think this is the most
compassionate thing the first thing i
thought when i saw that aside from
disgusting is
we need to put that thing down it's in a
lot of pain
what are you doing keeping it alive for
it
you see this a lot of these kinds of
videos with you know some
people's pets that are like way past
their last leg they don't even have any
legs anymore
and they're just keeping the animals
alive make you know
a dog with four wooden legs that carted
around in a wheelbarrow it's supposed
it's supposed to be uh it's uh so it's
so heartwarming no that
it's an animal and it's in pain and
you're just keeping it alive for your
own sake because you think it's cute
that's the most merciful thing with an
animal when it's injured
basically when an animal can no longer
perform its most crucial function like a
bat that can't fly anymore
you put it down because it's an animal
and it's in pain that's the best thing
you could do for it
i made this point on twitter and a bunch
of people told me but he looks happy
he's so happy what do you mean he looks
happy what
do you know what a happy bat looks like
tell me the difference between a happy
bat and a sad bet
i'll line [ __ ] i'll line 10 bats up in
front of you
tell me who's this who are the sad and
happy bets how can you tell
dr doolittle now we have all
watched wait we've been brainwashed by
disney
we grew up on these disney movies and
pixar movies uh with the
anthropomorphized you know
animals and so now we think we can just
assume their emotions
whether whether animals even whether our
bad even has emotions is a
is a question uh you know in and of
itself
but no the most merciful thing there
with that bat is to
kill it and that's
the lesson there in animal mercy
uh move on to our to our latest most
exciting segment i think
the segment that i've dubbed reading the
youtube comments because this is where i
read
some of the youtube comments um and if
you
you know if you want me to read your
comment all you have to do is uh is
leave one if you watch the show on
youtube
um so we'll read a couple of these from
the show yesterday
someone 99 says imagine a group of race
gender and pc obsessed people
then imagine these bubble wrapped
children in adult bodies walking on
eggshells around everyone all day
other than being the butt of jokes
nobody would really care what this woke
crowd thinks unfortunately
this group of virtue signaling zombies
scared of their own shadow
are in positions of power today very
well put
some 199 i i ve very well put
eloquently put but i also think i go
back to what i said at the beginning of
the show
we make a mistake when we assume
you know the way you're you're
presenting it here is that these are
overly sensitive snowflakes right
and that that may be the case for a lot
of people
but someone like aoc for example someone
position of power
no not overly sensitive at all
this is this is a cynical power grip
they know exactly what they're doing
so when they pretend to be offended by
something that isn't really offensive
they try to cancel someone for some
innocuous thing
it's it's not that they're that they're
actually being sensitive they know what
they're doing
but they're doing but they're this is a
this is a a ploy
for power so it's actually a lot worse
than how you put it
because at least if they were actually
overly sensitive and just being
emotional babies well that would be a
problem
but at least in that case they're being
sincere there's no sincerity here it's
all an act
it's a stage performance uh
tomato joe says oh dear now that i know
there's a chance matt will read my
comments i hope i can come up with
something insightful to say
well you failed tomato joe you failed
it's the last time i read a comment from
a guy named tomato joe i can tell you
that
micah says i see your point in regards
to karen i guess as a white person the
reasonable
the reason why i don't take offense is i
don't care for karen's either
this isn't a shot at all white women but
women who behave like this it represents
whites in a bad light
and they need to be called out yeah i
discussed yesterday that karen
is it's a it's a racial slur and it
actually is that's
that's that's how was intended that's
how it originated and this is the
response i've heard from a lot of people
that you know i don't have a problem
with the karen thing because the people
that are called karen i don't like them
either
well i understand that the people who
are typically labeled that way
i also i feel the same way i i have no
sympathy for them
but that um
excuse would never work
right in any other situation
if there was a racial slur towards any
other race
you couldn't defend it on the basis of
saying well yeah but the people that we
use it against are you know
deserve it right so
that's my point that that excuse for
racial slur would obviously
not work in any other situation
or if you if you called a non-white
person some kind of racial slur
and you got called out for it you
wouldn't be able to say in your defense
okay but that person's a jerk even if
they were being a jerk
because the response is going to be okay
but that doesn't excuse using a racial
slur
and so all i'm saying is that exact same
logic should apply here
that's all uh justine says i knew this
would be a problem when hate crimes
became a big deal there was never a need
for that label if the activity was
criminal then fine it's a crime but hate
itself is not a crime
and no one can actually determine if
another person hates something
yeah that's exactly the problem and
that's why i said
you know conservatives made a big
mistake by
basically going along with the hate
crime designation oftentimes
conservatives will use it themselves
um but although every
most of the things that we call hate
crimes are actually crimes
unless it's a hoax like jesse smallette
labeling hate on it is to assume that
you can read the person's mind and that
you know
what the motivation was behind it and as
i said yesterday it also assumes
that even if they were motivated by hate
that hatred is the worst possible kind
of motivation
so he beats him up or kills someone and
if we can prove that you did it out of
racial animus and hatred then you're
gonna get the federal crime you gonna go
to prison for longer
yeah i mean as far as i'm concerned you
kill someone put you in jail forever
give you a death penalty probably is a
good
but um is that really a worse motivation
than just killing someone out of pure
indifference
or killing someone because you want
their money now what about
you kill someone because you want to
steal their shoes or you want to steal
15
from their wallet it's not that you hate
them it's just that their life means
nothing to you one way or another
i would argue that that is at least as
bad as hate if not a lot worse
so those are the comments uh and again
if you want to
chime in you could always leave a
comment on youtube you know unless
you're obscenely ridiculously wealthy
and you can afford to fly the private
jets around
then i'm sure you've had the experience
like we all have of just struggling to
stay ahead just keep your
head above water with your finances
that's something a lot of us have dealt
with
do you ever feel like no matter how hard
you work you just can't seem to get
ahead
if you look back through the last few
years and you just never have enough
money in the bank account or you only
have enough to pay your bills you're
planning you're on month to month with
your bills
that's not really the american dream
that we're hoping for
is it that's not what we're all looking
for it's not the dream we were promised
times are tough right now and a lot of
people have racked up all sorts of debt
whether it's credit cards consolidation
loans store cards
even those payday loans they can have
interest rates over 10 we know life's
been tough but the good news
is turbo debt is here to help banks
want to keep you in debt that's the
that's the dirty secret not much of a
secret
they only make money when you pay
interest so they they're interested in
you
being in debt almost 70 of americans die
with credit card debt and no money in
the bank you don't want to be
in that position turbo debt helps with
credit slash retail cards
personal loans payday loans medical debt
think about how much
you pay every month to credit cards
versus going into the bank as savings
preparing for your future you know
putting money in the bank for your kids
if you're paying 500 bucks a month
in just five years you would have thirty
thousand dollars in cash in the bank if
you didn't have
those high interest credit cards and so
you've got to take care of this
turbo debt is your solution if you have
over ten thousand dollars in credit
cards personal loans medical or payday
loans
they can help end the endless cycle of
debt and start investing in your future
now go to www.turbodebt.com
walsh for a free consultation and
if you haven't done this yet put this on
your um
on your to do list as well go to
dailywire.com and become a member now
you get 25 off we still have this deal
going it's not going to go forever
you can use promo code rhf to get 25
off and if you're using that rhf promo
code it means you're also getting a
chance to watch
run hide fight which is our new movie
it's our first movie our first foray
into you know making culture um making
entertainment
and it's a movie that people love 2 000
positive reviews on rotten tomatoes 93
you can go look for yourself this is
your last chance
to take advantage of this deal so use
promo code rhf to get 25
off your membership at daily wire join
us in this cultural fight today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're canceling the aclu and not
for the first time i'm sure not for the
last either
but we uh before we talk about the aclu
what it's done to get itself canceled
again
i want to play a related clip this is
not someone from the aclu but this is
biden's
biden's pick for education secretary
miguel cardona is his name
and here he is being questioned recently
by rand paul about the issue of trans
people and sports this is what he said
what do you think in general about boys
running in girls track mates
like they've been doing in connecticut i
think that
it's critically important that educated
education
systems and educators respect the rights
of all students including students who
are transgender
and that they are afforded the
opportunities that every other student
has to
participate in extracurricular activity
does it bother you that like the
top 20 percent of boys running in track
meets beat all of the girls in the state
and that it
you know would you know completely
destroy girls athletics the girls are
being pushed out
they don't make the finals in the state
meet they don't get college scholarships
that it's really detrimental to girls
sports do you worry about having boys
running girls track meets
you know i i recognize and appreciate
the concerns
and the frustrations that are expressed
i've as commissioner of education
have had conversations with families who
have felt
the way you just described it in
families of students who are transgender
so i understand that this is a challenge
i look forward to working with you and
others to
do you think it's fair you gotta have
boys running in the girls track mate
i think it's appropriate for it's i
think it's it's the legal responsibility
of
schools to provide opportunities for
students to
participate in activities and this
includes students who are transgender
this is the answer of the defense we
always hear from public officials who
support putting
boys in girls sports that is we hear no
answer no defense there's no cogent
argument in favor of it
and they know it the only possible
argument is that it makes the boys feel
good to compete against girls but that's
neutralized by the fact that it makes
the girls feel not good when boys
compete
now i would say the girls feelings
outweigh the boys by considerable margin
in this case but
at its worst at worst it's kind of a
wash
offsetting penalties uh nobody wins on
that score
we can't settle the issue based on
feelings we'll have to look at the facts
then
the science and in that realm
there's really no argument to support
the left's position
which brings us to the aclu they have
helpfully
though unwittingly proved my point about
there being no arguments in support of
the left position on this topic
in a tweet thread this week the once
respected civil liberties organization
and those days of being respected were
long ago indeed but
they attempted to debunk what they call
the four
myths about trans people in sports
uh they explain quote attacks on trans
youth and sports are showing up in
dozens of state legislatures
nationwide these bans are discriminatory
harmful and unscientific
here's why and then they go through the
myths one by one
and attempt to debunk them so let's
let's review these
myth one says the aclu is that quote
sex is binary apparent at birth and
identifiable through singular biological
characteristics
that's the myth they say that sex is
binary here's the debunking
there is no one way for our bodies to be
women including women who are
transgender intersex
or disabled have a range of different
physical characteristics biological sex
and gender are not binaries
there are not set hormone ranges body
parts or chromosomes that all
people of a particular sex or gender
have
okay this is just one big twisted
pretzel of conflations and misdirections
first of all
notice how sex and gender are used
interchangeably
okay it used to be that gender is not
binary sex and gender are
two different things and and uh gender
is not binary but sex is different
um now gender and sex are both
not binary how do they prove this how do
they support the assertion that sex is
not binary and not a parent at birth
even though in almost every case ever in
history the sex of a child has been
correctly identified right away just by
looking at what's between the child's
legs
well they bring up intersex and disabled
people the point they're trying to make
is that in a very small minority of
cases
there are people born with mutations or
deformities or abnormalities that make
it difficult to determine their
biological sex
but this does not mean that there is no
biological sex or that their sex is
something
other than male or female it just makes
it harder to tell
and at any rate this has nothing to do
with transgender people
even if i agree that intersex people are
an exception to the
uh sexist binary rule which i don't
but even if i did that still would do
nothing to help the transgender people
who are not intersex
and this is a discussion about trans
people isn't it
so forget about intersex forget about uh
disabled
talk just about trans people if i need
to be more specific
non-intersex trans people what about
them
the aclu continues with myth too
athletes physiological characteristics
provide an unfair advantage over cis
athletes this again is supposed to be a
myth
perhaps next they'll debunk the myth
that the sun is hot
that the earth is round or that horses
are mammals or that gasoline is not
a beverage maybe these are all myths who
knows
but here are the facts as told by the
science denying
lunatics at the aclu they say trans
athletes vary in athletic ability just
like cisgender athletes in many states
the very same cis girls who have claimed
that trans athletes have an unfair
advantage
have consistently performed as well or
better than transgender competitors
that's it that's all they got that's all
they have to prove that boys don't have
a biological
advantage over girls in sports um yes
they're debunking the claim
that men have physical advantages over
women by pointing out that some women
sometimes can compete against
some men this is exactly like debunking
the claim that humans need to drink
water every day
by pointing out that some people have
lived for a week without drinking water
it is precisely the same logic
you're going with the outlier case and
trying to extrapolate a general rule
based on that
the actual facts are quite clear-cut
females
on average have less muscle mass smaller
fast twitch muscle fibers
smaller lungs smaller hearts shorter
legs much more estrogen much less
testosterone
a lesser capacity to produce oxygen when
they exert themselves and so on this is
but a partial list of biological
differences
and that is why for example everyone in
the nba can dunk
but no one in the wnba conduct it's why
the fastest female high school
sprinter in almost every state wouldn't
be in the top six among the males of her
same age
probably not even the top 20. it's why
no
female has ever successfully become a
navy seal it's why
well it's why our common sense intuition
and observation that men and women are
different
is accurate and that's it
those are the only two fact-based
arguments that the aclu tries to present
and they're both completely false and
delusional and borderline psychotic
the other two debunkings have to do
again with emotional concerns
as for science and facts this is all
they got
which is to say they got nothing
and for that reason they are canceled
but you know what
we're canceled too all of us in this
culture for allowing this madness to get
as far as it has
for failing to take this threat
seriously soon enough which we should
have
i mean there were some of us five six
seven eight years ago who were saying
we're going to get to this point this
transgender stuff this is where we're
going
and there were many people many
conservatives who told those of us who
were
warning of this that it's a passing fad
it's not a big deal we need to focus on
more important things
and even now um
the opposition people on the right
failing to launch a competent defense
um defense for of biology of basic truth
i mean the other side
are essentially flat earthers and
they're winning
in spite of that so we are cancelled too
everyone is canceled they aclu you me
you're all canceled damn it and we'll
leave it there for today
on that positive that typically positive
and chipper note uh thanks for watching
everyone thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 21. john kerry has no choice
but to fly around in private jets the
doj encourages yale to discriminate
against white and asian students and
marilyn manson's sex scandal
exposes the central political debate of
our age who to thunk it check it out on
the michael knowles show